why we need God to die for humans okay
now that's get the Salvation yeah I'm
I'm trying to get you to understand so
that's a different question so now you
you're forgetting the time Factor right
you don't care about the time okay okay
let's need that yeah when you say why
does God need uh well God doesn't need
anything he doesn't need to forgive you
he doesn't need to save you he can just
give you what you deserve that's the
first thing so you keep saying like when
you said God need God doesn't need
anything he doesn't need to anything he
didn't need to create you he didn't need
to create me he doesn't need to save me
he can give me what I
deserve so that's the first thing so we
have to get that straight so you
understand God doesn't need to forgive
you
right God doesn't need to forgive us
yeah does he have to forgive you or he
can just give you what what you
deserve
um like I'm not demanding God to forgive
me I didn't ask I didn't say you're
demanding I said God doesn't need to
right does he have to forgive
you it's really hard question though I
canot why would God have to forgive you
does he need you to exist for him to be
God so he doesn't have to forgive you
because he doesn't need no no like he
like he always exist I know that he
doesn't that's my point so he doesn't
have to forgive you
right okay y if he has to something that
means he's obligated and he's bound to
you but God is bound to no one he's
obligated to no one
right yeah so so let's establish first
God doesn't need to forgive anyone
right okay I just want to make sure you
understand because I'm helping you
understand uh what okay okay I get it I
get it okay so that part we got okay now
that we sa he doesn't need to he chooses
to now the question is here's the
question when God chooses to do
something or God chooses to say
something then Things become different
in other words he doesn't he didn't have
to choose to create he didn't have to
choose to punish
sin I he he didn't have to do any he
chose to do that now now that he's
chosen to
create now that he's chosen
to enjoin upon mankind rules regulations
to live by in order for them to enjoy
God and benefit from his creation now
things are different so now he created
Adam and Eve and he says to Adam and
Eve one thing I do not want you to do do
not eat of the the forbidden fruit the
tree of the knowledge good and
evil if you eat that sin because sin is
Disobedience to God's command see people
like to use the word sin sin simply
means breaking the law God has enjoyed
upon mankind so he was he gave them one
law one command don't eat the forbidden
fruit now he gave other commands such as
be fruitful meaning you know multiply
reproduce now if they didn't do that
that too would be sin because what is
sin I'm trying to help you understand
the the Bible theology a little deeper
so go a little deeper not too deep where
I confuse you if they didn't
choose to obey God and being fruitful
that too would have been sin
right because what is sin not obeying
God's command no yes okay so he gave
them actually if you look at it he gave
them the command of be fruitful multiply
through the Earth and I was reproduce
have children if they said no that would
have been sin they would have been
punished then he said do not eat of the
tree of the knowledge of Good and
Evil they did that sin because sin means
to break his law his commands but then
he told them here's the thing if you
sin disobey you will
die so now here's the thing the Bible
tells us for example numbers 23:19 now
Adam can he has to bring up the Bible
verses because I can't do it yes sir
numbers
23:19 the Bible tells us God is not a
man that he should change his mind nor a
son of man that he should lie shall he
say and not do in other words if God
says something he's going to do it
right yeah if he say something he GNA do
that yeah he doesn't go back on his word
he doesn't he says look you do this this
will happen you do that that will happen
so when he told
them you eat you die okay but they ate
now here's the Dilemma if Adam and Eve
had died that moment that means either
that would be the end of Humanity or God
would have to then create another pair
of human beings because they had no
children if he had demanded they die
that moment it would be the end of human
existence so either he' have to now
create another
pair and start over again
or he would show mercy and forgive them
and extend their life and not take their
life
away until they have children so that
the Earth would be filled with human
beings but by forgiving them he goes
back on his
word because he said no he didn't he
said you're going to eat you die
right y you're gonna eat you're gonna
die but God said hold on I don't want
them to die I want to extend them mercy
and compassion because God's desire is
not that human beings die and I want
them to reproduce so that the Earth will
be replenished filled with humans so
then he
didn't bring about the Judgment of death
he forgave them but now we have a
problem
God now violates his word goes against
his word goes against his Justice
because Justice is you get what you
deserve you do this this is what you get
well they sin what does Justice demand
they die well he didn't give them
Justice he showed them mercy so we have
two problems now this shows God is more
merciful than just and that God went
back on his word and did change his
mind so how how do we solve the Dilemma
the tension how can God still be
just and God
be a god of Integrity who keeps his word
but at the same time be a merciful
compassionate loving God by not giving
Adam and Eve what they deserve which is
death which then would end human
existence and then he'd either forget
about creating humans or he'd have to
create another
pair how can he be all of
that without being more loving and
compassionate than just and holy or more
just and holy than loving and
compassionate because now we have a
dilemma don't
we yeah you you've see the Dilemma right
y well now let me show you how God shows
you he solves the Dilemma let me show it
to you watch how God's going to solve
the Dilemma go to Genesis
3:21 oh Genesis 3:21 he's going to read
it yes I'm doing it yeah he's going to
read it okay notice how he solves the
Dilemma walk with me we're going to go
through this step by step as the Holy
Spirit helps me to help you for the
glory of Jesus so when I ask questions
it's to help you think deeper more
deeply
right so notice what God did for them
any translation that will make sense for
him if it's
old if Old English is hard then read
something else yeah I'm going to read
new King James also for Adam and his
wife the Lord God
made tinquist of skin and them tunics
meaning clothing right clothing that's
what it is t a tunic is like a robe
clothing right perfect okay but now uh
skin that means this robe was made out
of skin what skin they're they're the
only human beings
alive and at this point God doesn't
create anything new because in Genesis
131 after he finished the creation of
the female god stopped from his work of
creation cuz everything that needed to
exist was brought into being and he saw
it's very good and he entered his
seventh day of rest rest meaning he
wasn't going to add to Creation now he's
just going to supervise creation sustain
creation and preserve creation so where
do you get these uh tunics of
skin
uh skin so it's from skin not human skin
Adam and Eve didn't die they're the only
human being
can you say it again like I didn't get
the
quot what how do you make clothing from
skin skin of
what two of skin you can't be human
right because they're the first humans
he didn't kill them and take their skin
and make clothing yeah like what's the
meaning of tunic so it's a well that's
why if this brother didn't read new King
James or New American Standard and if
you listen I said it mean robe garment
you went to up go down brother you
passed it up for for sorry sir which one
do you want me to read animal skins okay
okay I get it I get it yeah new new
American Stander Bible says garments
okay yeah new American stand yeah yep
garments of skin yeah
tunic robe it's a garment okay so the
these garments were made out of
skin what skin from
where from animals it
says well that's that that's a
paraphrase a paraphrase means it tries
to give you an explanation the meaning
what you read right there numeric C is
the literal meaning okay there is no
word animal in the
Hebrew all right so where would he get
the skin even in my in my translation I
was reading in my translation uh my own
Lang when you say it's animals too yeah
because they're helping you understand
where the skin came from but the word
animal is not the text so it gave it
away for you so he made the garments
from the skin of
animals we don't know that yeah but he
got to be animals because there's no
other type of skin he could make the
garments from right he can't make them
from
humans yep so the only skin left would
be that of animals the Beast that he
created right yes yes so the only thing
we don't knows which animal he use that
we don't know okay but you understand
for him to make a garment from animal
skin that means he had to cause an
animal to die he had to kill an animal
right yeah that's the
principle God says You must die when you
sin but now because I want to show you
mercy and extend your life I'm going to
have an animal die in your place so he
dies the death you deserve so you can be
spared and I can show you
mercy so here from the beginning God is
showing you that when I say the soul
that sins must die you have to die so
either you will die or you can choose to
accept my
substitution a substitute who dies in
your place so you can be
spared so now you see it's pointing to
Jesus isn't
it yeah it makes sense I can understand
but now it's going to get a little
deeper okay
animals do not have the value and the
worth of humans
right in the eyes of they don't have
okay so so an animal cannot suffice to
pay the death of Disobedience sin
breaking the law brings death this is
why if you find in the Old Testament God
is having them repeatedly sacrifice
animals in their place because one
animal cannot pay the debt for all human
sins that will be committed from this
moment on no no one animal because an
animal doesn't even have the same value
of one human life let alone millions of
human lives
right now we have the other dilemma
though we don't have any sinless human
beings who could then die voluntarily in
the place of another human and even if
we did a human life is equal to a human
life eye for an eye tooth for tooth life
for life right yeah so even if say you
are sinless and you die your value your
the value of your human life is only
equal to another human life it it's it
doesn't have the
value that can equal all human lives
because you're not better than anyone
else you're just as good and equal right
okay yeah like just like a one and one
like it like the for ey like the law the
law says you know eye for an eye tooth
for a tooth life for life in other words
if you if you murder some someone right
then they take your life they don't take
your life and your children's life right
yeah yeah because soul is equal to Soul
life is equal to life right yes yes so
even hypothetically if there was a
sinless human being all he can do is pay
the debt of another human life because
his human
life
doesn't equate to all human lives
because he's not better
he's just he's on the same level as
other humans so it's life for life right
yeah so now who
then is able to pay the debt of all
human sins to cover the debt of all sins
that have been committed and will be
committed so that now when a human wants
to be forgiven and not be given Justice
what he deserves or she deserves the
payment has been made all they have to
do is off accept the payment and all
their debt will be
cancelled who alone is able to pay the
debt of all human
sin animals cannot do that and humans
cannot do that so only God can do that
ah but now hold on it's a human sin
which means it requires a human death
how can God then pay the debt of of
human sin by dying the death of a human
being when he's
Spirit Why Not
Angels brother who told you angels are
better than
humans uh I was thinking does no that's
not biblical it's not even even the
Quran it's not quranic but forget the
Quran for
now don't you believe from your former
muslamic days that humans are higher
than Angels or at least the righteous
are and or at least
Muhammad yeah but uh how can an angel
how can an
angel carry the debt of all human sin
and pay the debt of all human sin even
if he's better than a human uh how many
human lives is he better I mean in other
words if we take Michael the Angel
Michael let's assume he's better okay
how much better so better that he his
his one life is better than all human
lives combined okay it makes sense right
now okay if an angel die in the human
place the angel would be a
god exactly so he can't do it can he
yeah I can understand only God has
infinite value and worth so that only
God can pay the debt for all human sins
and still not be depleted in funds just
to use a human analogy right because
he's infinitely Rich right y but the the
problem is it's a human sin which
requires a human death but God is spirit
so how can he pay the human
debt so that means he have to become a
human you answered it for yourself and
welcome to Jesus Christ